okay first of all first of all okay swat
has gone international
what was the best part
about working in mexico uh best part of
working in mexico uh honestly um look
i've done this for i've done this for 29
almost 30 years um to be the lead of a
show i'm very proud of that but i can't
do anything by myself
um so i'm proud of all the people that
i've worked with i'm proud of the show
um
and to be able to live out my dream and
tell stories and be a superhero cop uh
but then to find myself i'm a black man
in real life i'm a black man honda is a
black man from south l.a shamar moore
the real guy i'm from east oakland how
did i end up in mexico on a horse and uh
but but the fact that the producers uh
found an interesting way to portray this
character and to present this show we
still kept the integrity of swat and
that you know
it's still about it it's it's still
about
finding justice it's about finding
fairness it's about
the good guys you know dealing with the
bullies and so to to to kind of peel
back the layers of the onion the layers
of the onion of of this character hondo
because he's so he's always on top he's
always the boss he's the bad man but now
you find him a little bit cracked
questioning himself so you see he's so
so as fun as our show is we still
give a nice dose of humanity um
and authenticity and so you just see the
struggle of a person and i think
everybody can relate to that and it was
done in such a beautiful way we were in
tefl salon mexico which is two hours
outside of mexico city it's some of the
most beautiful beautiful
countryside you've ever seen i'm
standing there in real life on a horse
standing there looking at the scenery
and it looks fake it it does not look
real
this looks like green screen you know
volcanoes and it just it's so plush and
it rains a lot there so everything's so
beautifully green and horses and cows
and dogs and
lots of dogs and cats and
big-ass frogs and wonderful food and
good tequila and really nice
um so when you watch the mexico episode
it really looks so grand it's we made a
full-on movie
that for tv it looks like a high quality
expensive movie that we were able to
create with a wonderful story yeah hundo
horseback riding and you make it look so
easy like is there an equestrian inside
of you that we just didn't know about
baby i promise you i just look like this
i was trying to tell you that in person
and you know you just you know you want
to fight it you want to fight him like
what do you what do i always hear oh
shmar
i'm like no but this ain't no game it's
like okay i learned how to ride a horse
when i was eight years old real life at
eight years old up until
i rode pretty consistently until i was
about 13 years old and then through life
uh you know i wrote here and there just
for fun uh and then i've done a couple
projects i did a a mini series called
mama flores family
tyson queen latifah
mario ben peoples uh what am i missing
but i but my character i got i was a it
was a period piece where i was a slave
owner i was a light-skinned black man
who's a slave owner so it's interesting
i got to ride a horse and so fast
forward now suddenly i'm going to ride a
horse in mexico and swat i'm like wait a
minute i'm lapd swat i ride around in a
cool car and a big truck and i chase bad
guys now i'm going to be riding a horse
and i was like okay and so i got with
oba tunde who plays my father on the
swat uh he plays hondo's father and he's
a real life cowboy like legit he's a
singer a dancer an actor he just got
inducted into the cowboy hall of fame
like he's a legit cowboy owns horses
like he's the thing so i said hey put me
back on the horse so i can get
comfortable and we rode for a couple of
days before i went to mexico and because
i i just and that and that was my
favorite part of mexico in that show
like i ran around and i saved the day
and i was honda when i was that bad man
that bad good man that we all know but
my favorite part was any time i was on
the horse and they were catching me on
the phone i was like yo i'm getting paid
to be a cool guy
to ride a horse this is pretty dope
yeah
swat has moved to friday nights what
does a typical friday night look like
for you
what does a friday night look like uh
actually i'm working the swat
works tuesdays through saturdays yeah so
i normally am working until around seven
eight o'clock and then i come home and i
have a drinking drink and uh i chill out
uh my weekend doesn't kick in until our
weekends are sunday and monday so i have
this thing called sunday fun days um
which you may know a little something
about um so uh
as far as the show is concerned
um i i think it's really great that
we're on fridays um
because we're not up against uh because
we had we had a bad time slot but it
shows how cool our show is people still
found us we were on at 10 o'clock at
night and people go to sleep now we're
on at 8 o'clock at night where
everybody's awake the kids are awake so
more people can see it you know they
don't have to wait and dvr it and the
whole thing um and it's it's a it's a
family-friendly show you know outside of
parents who don't want their kids to you
know see guns but we don't we're not a
horrific show we're not a dark show
we're more of an optimistic fun
show it's just kind of like a fun movie
um but to be on be on friday nights uh
is better for the show the ratings are
have been great uh more people are
getting to see the show i literally
drive around in my daily routine and
people like oh i didn't know about swat
yeah because you weren't awake
now
now people are
getting getting a dose of slot and uh
and the show's starting to take off so
i'm digging
you